une information vient de tomber
une explosion serait survenue dans un
quartier nord de la ville la police n'a
pas encore fait état du nombre de
victimes
la situation évolue rapidement restait à
la ville où on a entendu un bruit énorme
il y avait de la fumée partout et une
grande partie de l'édifice est bel et
bien effondré à l'international
maintenant une explosion a secoué gotham
city plutôt se vend désormais de source
sûre que le milliardaire et philanthrope
route sous lé coup
si vous voyez cette vidéo je suis mort
fiacco noir
message a automatiquement été envoyées
lorsque j'ai détruit la bat cave et tout
ce qu'elle contenait
nous savons que les criminels de gotham
vont vite se rendre compte que batman a
disparu
ne comptez pas soulagé cbd ils n'ont
plus confiance depuis la mort de tri
gotham a besoin de ses protecteurs plus
que jamais
[Musique]
je vous laisse le beffroi comme quartier
général le matériel est plus tout jeune
mais
trouverez de quoi vous équiper ainsi que
tous mes dossiers vous étiez toujours là
quand j'ai besoin de temps
vous ferez ce qu'il faut pour que ta
bonne chose et adieu
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est pour tous un secret
sur la cour nul ne dit mot
qui ose contre elle s'est dressée
devient
la fois des narcos